Okay. What's up, young man? Go ahead.
Oh my gosh, Sam. Uh,
you driving again?
I'll pull over right now. Don't worry.
What's the question?
So, it's just uh your opinion on
something. If this is a hard question,
we can't hear you. What?
Uh, can you hear?
Sorry. Can you hear me now, Sam?
Yes. Go ahead.
So, this is just um just a question on
your opinion on something. And this is a
hard question. I'm sorry. What is your
opinion on the death penalty? And um
looking at that through a Christian
lens,
it's in the Bible. The death penalty is
in the scriptures.
But um so then it's in the scriptures
under the the law that Moses gives them.
But that's a lot.
You sure?
No.
You sure it's
Moses gave them or was it given to Noah?
Genesis 9 46. M
okay I see what you're saying because I
was going to say if Moses
too much hookah too brother
well I mean no but
I was I was going to say that um if it
was Moses I gave it to him that's to
establish a theocracy but us who live in
America
Genesis 9:es 4-6 is pre Moses and Romans
13 1-7 is after Moses where he says the
governing authorities wield the sword
not in vain to execute evildoers
interesting
So, as Christians, we're not supposed to
be opposed to the death penalty.
No. Who told you you are?
I mean, uh, no, no one told me, but my
thought process because I'm go I go back
and forth with it because there are some
very evil actions that people do and it
makes you want them to get the death
penalty. But,
for example, how can someone repent if
they get killed or if they get executed?
Sorry.
So, did God not know that? That if you
execute them, they can't repent. So, you
caught God by surprise. Darn it. That
was a good one. He caught me by
surprise.
Yeah, I guess God is fair. So,
yes.
Okay.
So, if I just told you God said through
Noah before Moses that if you murder
someone then you have to be put to death
by a man. Genesis 9:es 4-6 and this is
before Moses. Then Paul says in Romans
13:1-7 that the authorities that are
instituted and at that time would be
Rome. They do not wield the sword in
vain, but they are a terror upon
evildoers because they have the sword to
execute those who are promoting evil and
anarchy. And Paul says this after the
Mosaic covenant. What grounds do you
have to say capital punishment is not of
God when I just told you before Moses
and even after Moses time of Paul
because that's why you have civil
authorities to then put people to death
who deserve it.
Okay. Um I know this might be like a not
really a fair uh comparison but I'm
going to say it just to see what you're
going to say. Um, Aba Moses the Black,
right? St. Moses the Black.
Yes.
He had murdered and I believe raped
several people, but he was the obviously
the leader of a gang. So,
David, right?
So did David. David murdered a man to
cover up the fact that he got his wife
pregnant and God didn't kill him dead.
Why are you confusing exceptions to the
rule with the general rule? And why
would monks need to put Moses to death
when it's not the duty of Moses uh the
monks to inflict capital punishment?
That's the right of the government, the
civil authorities. You don't take the
law into your own hands.
Okay. So, so as a Christian living in
the world and that's very political, we
we're I guess
you would support it, right? The death
penalty. You would support it.
I'm so sorry, Sam.
You want to repeat the same answer
again? No, I'm against Genesis 9 and
Romans 13. I'm against that.
I against what God says. You know what,
God? I don't care what your word says.
Okay. You're you're you're it it's just
the the problem is like I you know you
see the US now and like western
countries they're becoming very
corrupted. So like eventually one day
well they're corrupted. That's why there
is anarchy and murder and crime is
spreading. You know why? Because they
didn't check the evil from to begin
with. So a murderer knows he can either
get away with it or he'll spend his
entire life in a prison cell. Three
meals a day at taxpayers's expense. So
there's no deterrent for him not
murdering.
Whereas if you inflict swift punishment
upon the wicked, that will then strike
fear and tear in the hearts of others so
that they will now fear God and refrain
from doing these acts because the same
thing will happen to them.
Yeah. Ju just god forbid one day death
penalty starts being imposed on
Christians which I mean just for being
Christian you know
you mean so in the first century when
Christians were being killed and fed to
the lions and god forbid already
happened so just because someone takes
something good and corrupts and misuses
it
doesn't mean that means we then say
there is no basis for capital punishment
that's true that's very true all right
I'll stop smoking the hookah Sam I'm
sorry
please put it down and send it to that
guy from the Balkans
Okay. All right. Thank you so much, Sam.
God bless you.
Yep. That's how it is. This is what
scripture says.